vainqueur du scrutin des municipales
philippe guiguen a été officiellement
élu maire des clayes-sous-bois lors du
conseil d'installation vendredi 3
juillet il a également nommé ses neuf
conseillers municipaux
si nous voulons avoir une proximité avec
les questions dans tous les domaines
et comme je les dis être compétents et
réactifs
je souhaitais avoir neuf adjoints parce
que un maire c'est un homme orchestre il
peut pas maîtriser tous les tous les
sujets la seule candidate de la
triangulaire aux élections a souhaité
prendre la parole lors de ce conseil
d'installation dans une ambiance tendue
elle est revenue sur la campagne
agressive et les nombreuses attaques
sexistes de son point de vue il me
paraissait important en effet de revenir
sur cette campagne délétère et c'est
important que je le dise ce soir on a pu
remarquer ce soir que la seule personne
qui a été hué c'est moi une femme
la réflexion de monsieur le maire je
reconnais la plume ça veut dire qu en
effet une femme je ne suis pas capable
d'écrire ça c'est à l'image de la
campagne une opposition représentée
également par nicolas eu
il a interpellé plusieurs fois le
nouveau maire également sur le
déroulement de la campagne mais aussi
sur la composition de la nouvelle équipe
le renouvellement de l'équipe municipale
on attendra puisque sept des adjoints
élus sont
issu de l'ancienne majorité était déjà
adjoint et puis sur l'ensemble des
décisions
délégation de compétence qui ont été
déléguées à monsieur philippe big n est
bien celle ci sont les mêmes que
lors de 19 années précédentes le
prochain conseil municipal se déroulera
à l'espace philippe noiret jeudi 9
juillet à 19h30 avec notamment le vote
du budget